as we mentioned that fire is raging near
a community that is mourning the loss of
12 people gunned down at a bar filled
with college students hundreds of people
gathered last night to remember the
victims of Wednesday night's shooting
this morning we know many of their names
and will share their stories in a moment
we're also learning more about the
former marine responsible for the attack
Carter Evans is outside the borderline
Bar and Grill in Thousand Oaks Carter
good morning good morning this is still
an active crime scene here investigators
are inside the borderline bar and grill
behind me gathering evidence and now the
community of Thousand Oaks once
considered one of the safest cities in
America is coming to grips with this
terrible tragedy at a vigil Thursday
night hundreds joined in song inside the
Thousand Oaks Civic Arts Plaza while an
overflow crowd gathered outside to
remember those who were lost
Mariah pieszecki says two of her best
friends were killed it feels like a
dream but I wish that I could just wake
up from it in here for both of them
again gunfire can be heard in dramatic
new cell phone video recorded during the
attack police say the gunman appeared to
fire at random they ran out of back
doors they broke windows unfortunately
our young people are people at
nightclubs have learned that this may
happen according to authorities the
shooter was 28 year old Ian long a
former Marine combat veteran who'd been
stationed in Afghanistan police say long
used a 45 caliber Glock handgun with an
illegal extra capacity magazine first
shooting a security guard outside the
bar witnesses say he deployed smoke
bombs before going in and aiming at
employees and customers I heard the
shots and I took everyone kind of just
got down and started freaking out
running around in a Facebook update
attributed belong by CNN which says it
was posted around the time of the
shootings he writes I hope people call
me insane yeah I'm insane but the only
thing you people do after these
shootings is hopes and prayers and
wonder why these keep happening on
Thursday police searched the home long
shared with his mother there were rumors
long suffered from PTSD Long's high
school track coach says he physically
assaulted her as senior year but she
never filed charges hundreds of
thousands people with PTSD they don't go
around shooting people
this kid was mentally disturbed in high
school I just wasn't disbelief
Todd Stratton who was at the bar with
two friends who died says he's known
long for years like my friend killed my
other friends I was just there to see it
all happen and I didn't think they he
was the sort of person I would do this
and I don't understand it long had a
run-in with law enforcement
earlier this year neighbors called
police when they heard yelling and
screaming and crashing sounds coming
from his home they called a crisis
response team and long was cleared by a
mental health professional they felt he
did not need to be taken in for
evaluation
Liana clearly he had a lot of issues
Carter thank you so much